what I want to do in this video is get
some practice or become familiar with
what different angle measures in radians
actually represent and to get our
familiarity we're going to start with a
ray that starts at the origin and moves
along and and and moves and points along
the positive x-axis so this start with
this magenta ray and we're going to
we're going to rotate it around the
origin counterclockwise by different
angle measures and think about what
quadrant do we fall into if we start
with this and we were to rotate by
counterclockwise by three PI over five
radians and then if we start with this
and we were to rotate counterclockwise
by two PI over seven radians or if we
were to start with this and then rotate
counterclockwise by three radians so I
encourage you to pause the video and
think about starting with this if we're
to rotate counterclockwise by each of
these what what quadrant are we going to
end up in so assume you have had you've
you pause the video and you tried it out
on your own so let's try this first one
3 PI over 5 so 3 PI over 5 so we're
going to start rotating so if we get if
we go straight up if we if we rotate it
essentially if you want to think in
degrees if you rotate a counter
clockwise 90 degrees that is going to
get us to PI over 2 so that would have
been PI a rotation a counterclockwise
rotation of PI over 2 radians now it's 3
PI over 5 greater or less than that well
3 PI over 5 3 PI over 5 is greater than
or I guess in other word could say it is
3 PI over 6 is less than 3 PI over 5 you
make the denominator smaller you're
making the fraction larger so 3 PI over
6 is the same thing as PI over 2 so let
me write it this way so 3 PI over 2 is
less than 3 PI over 5 so it's definitely
passed to this we're going to go past
this now does that get us all the way
over here if we were to go essentially
be pointed in the opposite direction
instead of being pointed to the right
making a full you should say 180-degree
counterclockwise rotation that would be
PI radians that would be PI radians but
this thing is less than PI pi would be 5
5 over 5
so this is less than PI radians so we
are going to sit we are going to sit
someplace someplace and I'm just
estimating it if we are going to sit
someplace like that and so we are going
to sit in the second quadrant now let's
think about two PI over seven so two PI
over seven do we even get past PI over
two well PI over two here would be three
point five PI over seven so we don't
even get to PI over two we're going to
end up we're going to end up someplace
someplace over here this thing is let
it's greater than zero so we're going to
definitely start moving counterclockwise
but we're not even get to where this
thing is less than PI over two so this
is going to throw us in the first
quadrant
now what about three radians so one way
to think about it is three is a little
bit less than PI right three is less
than PI but it's greater than PI over
two how do we know that well PI is pi is
approximately 3.14159 and it just keeps
going on and on forever so three is
definitely closer to that than it is to
half of that so it's going to be between
PI over 2 and PI so it's going to be if
we start with this magenta this magenta
red we rotate counterclockwise by 3
radians we are going to get picture it's
probably going to be it's going to look
something it's going to be something
like this but for the sake of this
exercise we have gotten ourselves once
again into the second quadrant